hi guys and welcome to my guide to the
top five AFK money makers in old school
RuneScape now these are all geared at
low-level players or other players who
are looking to have an ALT account to
make money on so none of these are
highlevel requirements or high level
money makers they're all going to be
relatively low level and that can be
done whether you're a noob or looking to
make an ALT account all right let's get
started and starting in at number five
is going to be Fletching unstrung Maple
longbows now for this method you're able
to AFK for only about 50 seconds hence
why it's kind of at number five uh but
you're going to be profiting about
150k uh per hour and uh the requirements
for this are just 55 Fletching which is
going to be a little bit higher than
some of the others but it's actually
very quick to get 55 Fletching so all
you're going to do is withdraw a
inventory of maple logs and with a knife
you're just going to use it on there and
create uh maple long bows and you're
going to have to type in an amount I
just do 56 and yeah so you're able to AF
K here for about 50 seconds and for
experience wise this is why this is
actually kind of worth doing you're
getting about uh 90k an hour Fletching
experience so it's actually a really
good uh Fletching Training Method some
people do all the way to 99 just because
it's really easy profitable and pretty
decent experience and also AFK okay so
we just finished up our inventory of
maple longbows uh so the final product
is worth uh 2500 pretty well and we
bought all the logs for like 10 each but
we'll do a price check of those as well
uh so under 90 so we're making about uh
2,300 and it took about 50 seconds with
banking that's about a minute so time 60
you're looking at 138 and sometimes up
to 150k an hour so not
bad and number four is smithing
cannonballs now this is a very popular
uh method and for good reason the amount
of time you can AFK here is quite a lot
uh if you time it out it's about 2
minutes and 45 seconds roughly that you
can sit here just because of how long it
takes uh for each Cannonball to be made
now uh you will need one requirement to
make cannonballs uh that is the dwarf
Cannon Quest complete uh but it's a
pretty easy Quest honestly and doesn't
really take that long uh beyond that
you're going to need 35 smithing uh but
still not a super high requirement uh
from this you're going to be able to
profit about 130 to
150k uh per hour and as far as
experience you're going to get about
14k um an hour which is pretty decent I
guess it's free smithing experience just
because of how AFK it is uh but not
great but the reason this is above the
other method is mainly just because of
how long you can AFK here for almost 3
minutes of not being at your computer is
very good okay so we finally finished
the inventory so now just quickly price
check this for you guys uh so we bought
all the steel bars for 14391 roughly and
we Smith them into cannonballs which are
worth about 21k so that is a 6.6k profit
in about 3 minutes let's say 20 uh would
make it into an hour so about 132k an
hour not as much money but again very
afkable so that's why it's at number
four okay and at number three
surprisingly is baking potatoes uh as of
the current prices uh they're actually
about 180k per hour uh which is
extremely high for how little of a
requirement there is to do this all
you're going to need is well technically
only like seven cooking but I'd
recommend 40 uh cuz at that point you
won't burn the potatoes ever and they
have to be cooked on a range so we're
here in cathb right now which I think is
one of the closest ranges to uh Bank uh
now the AFK time here is about 1 minute
for cooking the potatoes uh and we're
getting only well let's see I think it's
only 20 or 30k um sorry it's only 17K uh
cooking experience per hour but
180k profit per hour is pretty decent
especially for the requirement okay so
we cooked an inventory of potatoes uh so
initially the potatoes are worth uh only
924 coins but once we cook them they're
going up to about 5k this o buddy guide
is a little inaccurate I just did just
price check it uh so 4K in profit let's
say and we can do uh 45 inventories an
hour uh is going to be about 180k in
profit uh which is exceedingly good for
this skill level coming in at number two
is going to be uh cutting diamond bolt
tips now to do this you're just going to
require 65 Fletching again it is a
little bit higher but it's very quick to
get Fletching levels uh so once you get
65 all you're going to need is uh well
you need a little bit of money to get
started because um buying the diamonds
does cost a bit but uh you can just do
an inventory sell it do an inventory
sell it uh but all you need to do is
withdraw an inventory of diamonds uh so
27 diamonds with a chisel and you're
just going to cut them all uh the AFK
time here is about a minute and 20
seconds uh so a little bit longer than
the potato method the only thing that's
not great about this method is the
experience rates you're only going to
get about 10K Fletching experience per
hour which is really bad uh but mainly
we're in it for the money so that's why
we put this at number two okay so we
just finished up our inventory of
diamond bolt uh so we ended up buying
these diamonds for
2214 and uh we're going to just do for
27 of these so 2214 * 27 so we spent
about
59.7k and if we check the price of
diamond bolts right now it looks like
they're at uh
218 uh so we pop them in here for 218 to
sell and it looks like they're going to
sell for
70.6 7600 minus uh
59 500 something anyway it's about 10 or
11k and since we can do an inventory in
about 90 seconds that leaves us with
about 40 inventories an hour uh so we're
going to make 400 to 450k an hour uh
doing this method which is pretty good
and finally last up is going to be uh
charging air orbs uh this is something
that is a little bit higher of a
requirement you need 66 magic to do this
uh that being said you can AFK this for
about a minute and a half which is nice
it does have a bit of a lengthy run to
get there but uh it's actually pretty
good for AFK and I've it quite a bit cuz
the actual time you're spending charging
the orbs does take quite a while uh and
this method varies in how profitable is
for hour right now it's only about 300K
which is on the low end I've gotten
about 500k an hour here as well uh and
So currently it's actually not as
profitable as um cutting diamond bolt
tips but historically and more
consistently this method is better and
plus it does give more experience giving
you about 35k magic experience per hour
uh so once you have 66 magic you're
going to come to Edgeville uh with the
following items you're going to need uh
81 Cosmic rooms per run cuz it's going
to take three uh per air orb you create
you're going to need an inventory filled
of unpowered orbs now for your in or
your equipment uh you want to bring as
much weight reducing gear as possible
but since you are going into the
Wilderness I wouldn't bring any you're
not willing to lose I'm not sure if it
drops on the ground or not either way I
just play it safe and not bring full
graceful I just bring a couple pieces of
graceful and the boots of lightness are
easy to get again so I just check my
death items kept on death and looks like
we're going to keep all my important
stuff so from Edgeville uh you're going
to want to run all the way down south
and then go into the uh Edgeville
dungeon from here you're going to run uh
North and you can see a bunch of other
people doing it so if you get super lost
you can just follow them I guess uh but
from here you're going to run north and
then East through the gate which is
usually open but sometimes not North
through another gate here then you're
going to run past the chaos Druids
sometimes it'll ask you to uh if you
want to enter the Wilderness uh so that
is a warning from now on you are in the
wilderness you only go to about level
five or six Wilderness so it's not super
dangerous uh but sometimes there are
some people like to PK Bots there even
though it's absolutely pointless for
them um but anyway it is possible to die
and have died but if you're paying
attention it's not a big deal uh you're
going to run past the black demon so if
you're super low level uh you might want
to get some higher defense levels and
once you get up this ladder you're at
the air Obelisk someone got P anyway
yeah be a little Mindful and then you're
going to use your spell on the Obelisk
and then make all so now you can pretty
much AFK for a minute and a half go do
whatever you want and come back and once
you're done you're just going to
teleport back to uh Edgeville okay so we
just finished our run and teleported
back to Edgeville and we just have uh
all the items here just so we can check
the prices uh so let's have a look uh we
turned all of these ingredients into air
orbs this is one sherp uh we got 30 30.
861k is what we can sell them for and if
we put in the ingredients uh it cost us
13 203 to make giving us a profit of
about
17600 uh per run and we did a run in
about 3 and 1 half minutes uh which
means we can do about uh 17 in an hour
roughly uh leading us to get about 300K
an hour now this very frequently will be
worth a lot more but still just as it is
it's pretty good K Money Maker and I
just decided to put at the top of the
list all right guys before I finish up I
would really like to go thank my patrons
over on patreon especially Robert D who
just uh bought my adamant tier of
support which is awesome that included a
shout out in the video so thank you very
much man appreciate it a lot and to
everyone else over on my patreon
definitely go check it out and thank you
guys for watching the video I'll see you
guys next time
n